sam tes talents sont nécessaires
quelqu'un nous a volé il est assez fou
pour voler l'entreprise
est-ce fait ce changement de plan ils ont
une fille de huit ans
je ne peux pas la laisser mourir
sam tu as tué les mauvaises personnes tu es
plus sous notre protection
des hommes méchants viennent nous faire du mal nous
devons aller là où c'est
sûr salut maman
suis-je un dieu grand-mère pas de
filles je pense voir un fantôme nous avons besoin d'
armes
vous aurez besoin d'une jane austen un
loup de virginie
et une agatha  Christie pour avoir lu
tu as l'ordre de tuer nous avons une
chance de mettre fin à cela
nous allons faire tomber le ciel sur leurs
œufs
je vais faire un peu de bruit alors quel est
le plan que
j'ai appelé en tant qu'uber tu te moques de moi non
c'est vraiment  dommage si je sors
de ça
vivant je viens pour toi
es tu un tueur en série ce que tu tues des
gens
oui et tu en as tué plus d'un c'est des
céréales
c'est plus compliqué que ça
toi